les québécois paient plus cher depuis
aujourd'hui le lait les produits
laitiers à l'épicerie on n'a pas tout de
suite avec marie claude morin bonsoir
bonsoir gerald des hausses de prix qui
vont de 4 à 6 pour ça c'est une
conséquence directe de l'augmentation du
prix du lait à la ferme
8,4 pour cent qui a été accordée par la
commission canadienne du lait c'était
annoncé cet automne ça entre en vigueur
aujourd'hui
au québec la seule province où le prix
du lait est réglementée la régie des
marchés agricoles a décrété des hausses
de 4 à 6% pour le livre lève pour le
lait standard ça veut dire je veux
sortir des exemples pour un litre de 2%
2 dollars 8 le litre c'est une
augmentation de 10 cents 4 litres
coûteront 7 et 89 ses 39 cents de plus
que l'an dernier c'est un peu plus cher
aussi dans certaines régions et c'est
une hausse assez importante quand on
regarde l'historique parce que ces dix
dernières années le lait de consommation
ont augmenté de 20% c'est moins que
l'ensemble des aliments qui sont à 25 %
ça s'explique par des coûts de
production qui ont vraiment augmenté au
cours des derniers mois chez les
producteurs c'est 13% d'augmentation au
québec on peut penser au coût de la
nourriture pour les animaux le carburant
la main d'oeuvre également les
fertilisants les transformateurs ont des
ondes etc ou à peu près 5% supérieur
entre autres l'emballage la main
d'oeuvre les transports ou également et
les épiciers ont aussi vu des hausses de
coûts donc tout ça mis ensemble fin en
sorte qu'on aurait pu voir des hausses
plus élevé on peut écouter sylvain
charlebois suivi du président des
producteurs de lait du québec
quand on regarde ce qui s'est passé au
niveau de la ferme et les calculs qui se
sont passées et avec ce qui se passe
ailleurs à l'épicerie
4 à 6% et une hausse que je considérais
comme modeste vraiment moi je
m'attendais 6 à 8% pour 2022
beaucoup de producteurs c'est clair que
je vous parle d'une hausse de 13 % des
coûts il ya certains producteurs qui
vont avoir des difficultés à rencontrer
leurs coûts de production mais c'est
clair qu'on est très conscient également
qu' un des fils au niveau des
consommateurs
il le prit d'ailleurs des autres
produits laitiers risque d'augmenter
encore plus que le lait de consommation
c'est là où ça va se passer parce que
plus de latitude pour les prix il ya une
augmentation de la consommation
également alors que celle du lait de
consommation diminue alors le fromage le
beurre
les produits transformés comme le yo
gourd auront probablement des hausses de
prix de 6 à 8% selon sylvain charlebois
ça pourrait être plus pour certains
produits même parce que le prix du gr de
beurre augmenté de 12% faudra voir de
quelle façon ça va se refléter sur votre
facture d'épicerie il ya des
négociations en cours entre les chaînes
d'épiciers et les transformateurs et
c'est plutôt ardu selon sylvain
charlebois
actuellement une guerre l'export sur des
transformateurs et les distributeurs le
parce que là actuellement les
transformateurs veulent justement
augmenter leurs prix en raison de coûts
de production plus élevés mais il ya
certains distributeurs génome répondent
qu'ils ne veulent pas payer cette
augmentation là
on va voir léo c'est évidemment à
l'épicerie mais probablement aussi au
restaurant on peut penser par exemple on
est derrière qui utilise beaucoup de
fromages à fait vrai merci marie claude
je vous en prie
avec nous ce soir luc boivin qui est le
directeur général de la fromagerie
boivin à saguenay bonsoir monsieur
boivin
alors on parle d'une hausse historique
un très impressionnante d'abord pour le
prix du lait à la ferme c'est très
impressionnant vous vous l'expliquez
comment qu'on en arrive à une croissance
aussi importante
écoutez je pense un des problèmes de la
gestion de l'offre c'est que
l'ajustement des prix se fait une fois
par année seulement au niveau de la
sociale on n'a pas de mécanique nous les
transformateurs ou c'est très difficile
d'aller avec des augmentations d'ordre
de ce calendrier l'eau qu'historique mal
au mois de février donc sa vie dans
l'année avec la commission canadienne du
lait qui qui fait une sorte d'évaluation
des coûts réels mais c'est une fois par
année qu'on arrive avec le montant oui
hélas au ciel faire une annonce au
niveau du lait la ferme donc son annonce
pour augmenter le revenu de la ferme qui
est qui est louable est nécessaire
daniel gauvin haut niveau la
transformation c'est un petit peu plus
compliqué parce que bon oui le coût du
lait à la ferme et il ya également
d'autres ou qui s'ajoute à ça on l'a vu
on est rentré dans une année pandémique
écorché par les ententes commerciales
qui ont affecté entre autres au niveau
des fromages les marges parce que bon on
est arrivé avec un off de l'extérieur
qui était très compétitive la pandémie
bonbons a répondu oui à l'effort de
guerre pour fournir des produits de
commodité dans les marchés mais tous ont
usé nos équipes on a fait face aussi à
une inflation qui est extraordinaire en
cours d'année donc on est pauvre on
n'est pas différent des autres secteurs
qui ont vu donner des coûts de carburant
des coûts d'emballage les coûts du
carton les le manque de main d'oeuvre on
ne peut acheter une au sahara pour nos
pauvres connu d'ajustement en cours
d'année il faut planifier pour la
prochaine année donc on n'est pas un
secteur qui de la grande capacité à
jongler avec un inflation qui est qui
est galopante l'inflation cette année ne
provient pas d'une pause la dame un
premier de l'incapacité de l'offre à
répondre à la demande et autant c'est
une inflation dans votre secteur qui est
encore plus importante que le niveau
d'inflation record qu'on voit
présentement de 4 5 % en 30 ans ben oui
il y avait qu il y avait quand même un
rattrapage à faire comme tu dis pendant
l'année mais on est un rattrapage de
l'année en cours aussi a vu du jeu
justement cours d'année baisse après un
groupe historiquement oui c'est une
mosquée qui majeur donc c'est quoi
l'impact sur votre production monsieur
boivin et sur le prix de vos fromages à
la consommation
là on s'en cache pas et on part on
jongle avec beaucoup de prix les gens
nous nous ne garderons assez vite pour
saint vith points 4 12% ou comprendre
que l'augmentation du prix du lait est
essentiellement sur la matière grasse
donc plus les produits laitiers
contiennent la matière grasse plus
l'impact sera grand niveau du coût de la
matière première pour les
transformateurs sept premiers points
maintenant à ça s'ajoute les autres
coûts donc on peut parler pourcentage
mais qu'attendre a même nous en usine
dont on parle de co kg avec le co kg a
varié de panama des produits donc c'est
une hausse cette année qui bossent bien
différent écouter on paie 30 degrés
différents le brésil au canada un
transformateur qui reçoit le même camion
citerne ne paye sa facture selon la
dernière utilisation du lait donc le
produit qu'on va avoir fait avec ça pour
le 32 bris grand prix du lait pensez-y
n'ont donc le peuple qui tranche de prix
là où une très différents selon les
produits un bon fromage de shebwa 20 à
40 dollars le kilo le ive augmenté de
convient mais chez nous on est dans les
produits de commodité donc des prix plus
bol fromage qui est en épicerie à à 28
d'or de kilo je connais pas la marge que
le l'épicier vaut s'y prendre mais dans
mon corps moi ça va représenter environ
2 heures 50 le kilo le coût du lait
quant à lui doit être autour de hand
soit 178 kg puis le reste va être pour
les autres coups qu'on a conduit en
cours d'année pour donner un exemple le
prix du carton augmenté de 30 à 40% le
pot de verre dans lequel on met notre
fromage fondu à tartiner le doublé en
raison du coût des conteneurs maritimes
a raison de
vivre avec une chaîne
d'approvisionnement qui a changé
était d une manufacturière juste à temps
maintenant ce qu'on voit c'est que le
jeta temps est très difficilement via en
raison de la pandémie puis je vous
dirais que l'on va voir des démos et des
années avant de revenir au modèle de
production qui était qui était normal
est ce que vous pourriez tenté d'ajouter
des ingrédients
augmenter la part d'un gradient un peu
moins de lait pour augmenter le
rendement sur sur vos produits
ben écoute et s'éteint dans notre camp
nou fromagerie boivin on est 100 % à
l'est c'est ce que l'utilisation
d'ingrédients laitiers c'est une c'est
une possibilité au canada il ya eu des
changements au niveau au niveau de
l'entente commerciale avec les états
unis savoir mener des changements j'ai
hâte de voir dans les prochains mois on
dit le cdh et la demande des prix de
l'offre dans le marché on risque de voir
certains joueurs qui vont augmenter le
contenu en ingrédients laitiers
avec des standards de composition qui
peuvent qui peuvent leur permet donc oui
oui c'est des choses qui sont possibles
et vous comprendrez que la gestion de
l'offre c'est un système qui réglemente
et quand on arrive au niveau de la
transformation
au niveau d'utilisation des ingrédients
c'est permis puis on est on est face à
un système qui est purement capitaliste
donc chacun vaut choisir de sa structure
de prix mais je peux vous dire une chose
c'est que le secteur la transformation
depuis 2006 la vie avec des beaucoup de
difficultés aux aliments ou de niveau de
l'ensemble des facteurs qui nous ont
contactés depuis merci monsieur boivin
c'est très intéressant très clair
surtout merci d'avoir été avec nous ce
soir
bonne soirée pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et
redit
oh